- Determination
- Determined
- Hello Believe Nation!
Today, we're going to talk
about how you can be determined,
and as always, as you're
watching the video, if someone
says something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the
comments below and put
quotes around it so that other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(swelling instrumental music)
- What is a world champion
boxer, a basketball player,
a track star, or a horse, even animals?
I find out that, this
Mark Spitz, for example,
he's a world champion, but what made him
the world champion was that he seemed to,
at the right time, when
the pressure's down, at
the last few yards, he can get that lead,
or he's got enough left to make it.
I fought Ken Norton, my last fight.
The fight was even up
until the last round,
but I had something that he didn't have,
although I'm much older, that
was the last minute kick.
- [Interviewer] What's
that last minute kick?
Is that something?
- It's the stamina, the
strength, the mental capacity
- [Interviewer] It's more
than training though.
- to realize what's involved
and how important it is
to make your body do something
it's really too tired
to do, your mind makes you do it.
Mark Spitz, this Olympic
track star was mentioning it.
He wasn't that much
greater than all the people
in the world, but sometimes
he won by just that much,
and a champion is just one
who can come out at the last
minute and close the show, as they say,
the star closes the show.
A 14, 15 round fight and
it's even and usually,
this champion, you can
depend on him to come
through at the last few seconds,
and find some energy in some words.
- [Interviewer] Is that mental discipline?
Is it discipline or?
- Not only that, it's mental and physical.
His body's in physical shape
to do it, plus, mentally too.
He's got himself in
condition where both fellas
maybe, sometimes, the
will can outdo the skill,
and sometimes a fella's
will is stronger than
the man who's actually better physically
and the determination
weakens the other man,
just to see him so determined.
- Did you doubt yourself, at any stage?
Cause it would be
understandable if you did.
- I never did, no, I
think there was definitely
times where, not in go-kart,
in go-karts, I was fierce.
No problems, no whatever.
Just get out and do what
I do, but I think there
was a moment when I moved to cars,
it was really hard.
The first few laps was
going really well and
then I spun off, I crashed.
Destroyed the back of the car,
and I was petrified
because I had to call Ron,
and tell him, and he's not an easy guy to,
y'know, but he was really supportive.
He's like "I know that this happens" and
then we did that first
few races, disaster,
and there was one day,
there was only one day
where we got home one day and we sat
in front of the garage in the car and we
were talking and it was
like a real down moment.
Y'know, like, maybe I'm not going
to be able to adapt to this,
from karting to cars, and then I went in,
had, normal dinner, went to
bed, woke up super early,
went training, next race, I won.
Y'know I just, if I ever
had a low moment, the next
day I just get up with
this determination, I don't
know where it'd come
from, but I just dug deep,
and somehow I just managed to find it, so.
- [Eminem] I was reserved and I was shy,
and had it in me, but wasn't quite sure
how to bring it out yet.
I wanted people to hear me so bad,
and I wanted to do my, but it was like,
them jitters and then, I'm
scared, I'm not scared.
That whole struggle and
everything, especially early
on for me, which I loved being on stage
and stuff like that.
Once I got a mic, I was
cool, but it was that,
it prompted me to do it
and get up there and not
be scared to grab that and just rock.
I feel like anybody can do
anything they set their mind to.
It depends on how bad you want
it, and I wanted to do it.
Y'know, at this stage
in my life I don't feel
like there's too much that I can't do.
I don't mean to sound cocky or nothin',
but if I like really,
really, want to do it,
I don't give up that easy.
- When we found out that
cash value life insurance
was a rip-off and "Buy Term
and Invest the Difference"
was the way to go, and they
had screwed our family,
I'm tellin' you what, I never forgave them
for what they did to my mama,
and what they did to me and Angela,
and I was out to punish 'em.
I wanted to hurt 'em,
and that's the way the
A.L. Williams people were,
and the more they tried to destroy us,
the just millions of wars
that we went through,
you know, when you're a
crusader, crusaders die hard,
and so it just made us more
determined to show 'em.
We wasn't going to let
those, the enemy, defeat us.
- As an aspiring entrepreneur, I know that
you've done a lot of things, I don't
want to go along with your credentials.
- Thank you.
- But know that we know that.
What do you do?
What did it take for you
to build your empire?
- Man, it took execution,
time after time after time.
You know what I'm sayin'?
Proper execution in many
different areas, and consistency.
It took resilience and
you just have to show up
and show out, so often.
- [Interviewer] Right on
- Time after time, you got to wake up,
and you got to drive, you got to be driven
to go get somethin' done, now.
I mean, for real, and
it's a gamble sometimes,
you got to really, really, you
got to be forward thinking,
ahead of the curve when it comes
time to make certain decisions.
You got to be willing to
stand on your beliefs,
cause a lot of times you're
the only one who can see it.
You dig?
Other people, they don't really see it,
but you got to really believe
in what you got inside of you
that's telling you and driving you
to a certain goal for something.
- [Interviewer] I can dig.
- Determination for me is far
more important than desire.
Desire comes from a place of
thinking "I need it" therefore,
the presupposition is, "I'm
not good enough, because
I don't already have it."
Determination is simply
a case of, well, here's
where I'm focused, here's where I'm going,
"I don't need it, I'm
just choosing to get it,
and get out of the damn
way, cause I'm moving."
- And by the way, there's
always been this kind of thing
in Silicon Valley of sort
of this, I call it the
"failure fetish", right?
Failure is good, right, I can tell
you guys have all been taught this.
Heard about this from a lot of people,
Failure is a wonderful thing,
failure teaches you all this stuff,
and it's great to fail a lot,
and we don't buy any of that.
We think that's all
complete, complete nonsense.
We think failure sucks,
(audience laughter)
we think failure is
a terribly, terribly
depressing thing to go through.
We think, success, on the
other hand, is wonderful.
You wouldn't think that
this is actually something
that you have to say out loud, but,
we do find it to be clarifying,
when we point it out,
and, so, we are strongly
biased towards people who
are so determined to
succeed that they just
never give up, they never quit.
I think that is a huge part of it,
and that's something we really look,
we try to look deeply for.
That's the kind of thing,
that's not listed on a résumé.
That's something that has
to be deep in somebody's,
fundamentally deep in
somebody's character,
and you have to see it
in their backgrounds.
- And another important
factor is determination,
and you should not think
that this development
can take place within a
few days or a few years.
We must understand.
You see that this
development may take eons.
(audience laughter)
So you see, our
determination, if you deeply
consider as a Buddhist and want to
really practice with the Dharma,
then, right from the beginning, you must,
you see, make up your
mind, or it doesn't matter,
it may take millions of
billions of billions of eons.
It doesn't matter.
What's the day?
After all, what's the purpose of all life?
The meaning of existence?
Nothing, utilize something positive,
then, you see, days or months or eons,
it is meaningful.
If you're really wasting your life,
purpose of life, then
even one day, too long.
So, once you determined,
once you make up your mind,
some kind of firm determination
and clear objective,
then time is not important.
So long as you see, prayer
and so long as pain and
suffering remains.
I will remain in order to serve.
That sentence, really gives
me something to understand,
and also I think inspiring.
So the morals is that impatience,
and as I mentioned before, we want
something done the quickest
or the best or something,
then I can reserve also,
poorest I think. (laughs)
The cheapest method,
quickest, cheapest method
results with the poorest. (laughs)
That's, I think, wrong.
So that, I would like to share with you.
I myself recite some mantra or some
visualization of mandalas,
but my daily practice,
although my practice very poor, very poor,
but even then, there is a main emphasis
on this Four Noble Truth
and Bodhicitta and Karuna.
So that really, I feel is
something practical then,
then through these practices you will
get something practical benefit.
Realizations from big deities,
sometimes I think cheat oneself,
almost is like cheating oneself.
- [Interpreter] Deceiving oneself
- Deceiving oneself!
So therefore, I think we must practice
step by step and with patience
and with determination.
Once you're involved, or
dedicated, or determined,
practice, then some
improvement, you can see.
You see year-by-year, or
at least decade-by decade.
Then you can see or, at least some change,
some improvement you can see.
Once you see that, that also gives you,
some kind of new encouragement.
So you see, change are not easy, not easy.
- Hey, when she was little,
and you know, like kids,
when they're little they're
like "I'm going to be a singer"
or "I'm going to be an
astronaut", did you ever,
for one moment, believe
that she would grow to be
as big as she is right now.
- Actually, as a child, she was
very childish to begin with.
As a child. (laughter)
- [Host] A very childish child actually.
- She was very determined, alright,
and we could see it, when she was four.
- I'm so embarrassed.
- You know, she would
stand in front of the piano
and just bang on the keys,
and then she wrote her first song,
it was, I used to play
"Money" by Pink Floyd,
and she wrote her first song,
it was called "Dollar Bill."
- [Host] I love that.
- And, Cynthia, my wife, she still has it.
- [Host] We should have that.
- You know it's because
you know, on that record,
they use actual money and
the register as instruments,
and I remember as a kid I
was so fascinated by that,
so my dad played me a
lot of great music that
made me really fall in love
with the idea of making it.
- The very minute that
you decide upon something,
you know that's what you want, you know
you're going to do it,
all of these negative that
have been bothering you,
they pick up their baggage and get out.
They just move out.
They can't live in the positive mind.
Can you imagine a negative frame of mind
and a positive frame of mind occupying
the same space at the same time?
Could you imagine that?
No you can't, cause it can't be done!
And did you know that the slightest
bit of a negative mental attitude
is sufficient to destroy
the power of prayer?
Did you know that the slightest bit
of a negative mental attitude is
sufficient to destroy your plan,
whatever it is you're doing,
carrying out your definiteness of purpose?
You have to move with courage,
with faith, with determination,
in connection with carrying out
your definiteness of purpose.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know, what did
you think of the video?
Did you enjoy it?
Is it going to have an impact on you?
What are you going to take into your life
or your business after
watching this video?
Please leave it in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to BestYouPRO.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
"Your One Word" and
snapping that picture of you
at the beach reading it.
I really really really appreciate it.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever, your one word is, much love.
I'll see ya soon.